carrusel de las artes maría carolina
piña
sí
[Música]
un cordial saludo desde nuestros
estudios en parís les damos la
bienvenida a este nuevo número de este
programa donde la cultura es noticia
esta semana en carrusel de las artes los
invitamos a conocer el mobile film
festival de parís un certamen de
cortometrajes móviles 100% digital y
gratuito dedicado este año al
empoderamiento femenino en tiempos de
kobe de viajaremos a suiza y bélgica
países que consideran al libro como un
bien esencial por lo que mantienen
abiertas las librerías a pesar del
confinamiento
se consideran un dúo francés de
exploradores de la música pop sensual
los charlotte fever son nuestros
invitados en la crónica musical
no
parís es el epicentro del festival
internacional de cortometrajes que lleva
por nombre mobile film festival un
certamen 100% online y que presenta
películas de solo un minuto de duración
hechas con un teléfono celular y de
hecho ese es un sello distintivo un
móvil un minuto una película para hablar
de este festival que se organiza en la
capital francesa vamos a conectar ya
mismo con claudia rodríguez quien es la
responsable de comunicación de este
festival claudia gracias por estar en
carrusel de las artes háblanos de esta
edición número 16 dedicada al
empoderamiento femenino y a la igualdad
de género que además coincide con el día
internacional de la lucha contra la
violencia hacia las mujeres que se
celebra cada año el 25 de noviembre
sí muchísimas gracias por la invitación
de parte de todo el equipo maria
carolina la idea del festival desde hace
ya varios años es realmente trabajar en
temática dar la voz a los cineastas de
todos los países para poder tratar temas
importantes que consideramos que es
importante tratar desde la cultura
entonces en años anteriores ha habido
por ejemplo una edición dedicada a los
derechos humanos ha habido dos ediciones
ya dedicadas al clima y al medio
ambiente y ese año bueno pues desde hace
mucho tiempo ya queríamos hacer una
edición centrada en los derechos de las
mujeres en el empoderamiento femenino
justamente hemos utilizado este título
en inglés muy mal es enfermedad porque
queríamos hablar de empoderamiento
queríamos poner el foco en realmente
sacar todas las fuerzas todas juntas
alrededor del mundo y contar historias
que llegan desde todas partes entonces
esta edición de efectivamente con esa
perspectiva feminista claudia y en este
año marcado por una crisis de el
coronavirus y cuando el sector cultural
estaba paralizado
ustedes han recibido un número récord de
cortometrajes venidos de todo el mundo
una parte positiva que tiene nuestros
festivales que es muy digital entonces
por eso nos ha afectado quizás menos la
crisis del colon amigos a este festival
en concreto pero quizás es cierto que no
esperábamos una acogida tan grande
gigante con un récord de todo porque
hemos tenido récord en tres partes no en
cuanto el número de cortos recibidos que
ha sido el año con más participaciones
en más de 1.130 finalmente en cuanto a
diversidad de países porque hemos
superado la centena de países llegando
haciendo un países participantes muchos
de ellos de américa latina' hablaremos
después y una tercera característica
también del récord de la que estamos muy
orgullosos y es que más de la mitad 57%
de las participaciones ha sido de
mejores cineastas entonces esto nos
enorgullece porque un festival dedicado
al empoderamiento de la mujer sin dar
voz a las mujeres no tendría sentido lo
decías claudia 60 cortometrajes en la
competencia oficial y cuatro de ellos
vienen de américa latina'
háblanos un poco más de estos cortos o
de que vienen de ecuador de venezuela y
de méxico
son dos hermanas que se llaman sal malta
y estefanía proaño ellas hicieron un
cuarto que se llama recordatorio para
las niñas del futuro un mensaje
bellísimo de esperanza para trabajar
para seguir trabajando para aprender
nunca dejar de preguntarse cosas y vivir
bueno pues al máximo no todas las
facetas de la mujer y sobre todo ayudar
a las generaciones futuras a que puedan
hacerlo tal y como nosotras seguimos
avanzando luego tenemos dos cortos de
venezuela uno que se llama la muerte de
un chivo de natalidad ella bueno hay una
especie de western muy interesante muy
bien firmado muchísima calidad artística
que nos lleva a este años de venezuela y
también desde la misma región
xcel selva alta hizo un cortometraje que
se llama anna sobre la violencia hacia
las mujeres y sobre todo en la época del
confinamiento en este periodo tan duro
que hemos vivido y como bueno pues un
mensaje también esperanzador para poder
salir de ese círculo vicioso y decir a
las mujeres tomen las riendas
y sigan adelante saliendo de esta
espiral de violencia estamos aquí para
ayudarlas y finalmente un corto también
muy fuerte la temática que viene de
méxico que se llama los invisibles y que
trata de la criminalización del aborto
en este país sobre todo hacia mujeres
indígenas y bueno pues la verdad un
testimonio muy duro basado en hechos
reales evidentemente y también con la
calidad artística de la realizadora
directora camila tamara demichelis
entonces pues una selección de cuatro de
la que estamos realmente orgullosos
claudia y lo interesante es que a partir
de esta temática de la mujer ha habido
una variedad de temas y de problemáticas
asociadas a la condición femenina con
historias que vienen de los cinco
continentes la verdad que hemos
intentado tocar todas las temáticas pero
realmente hemos visto que los
participantes los creadores han hablado
de tantos que más ha sido muy
interesante este proceso porque hablamos
de educación de las niñas hablamos de
menstruación de todos los temas de tabú
en cuanto al cuerpo de la mujer
acción del cuerpo femenino hablamos de
intentar eliminar la violencia contra
las mujeres del machismo de micro
machismo de dar fuerte tampoco a la
mujer en todos los ámbitos sociales
económicos políticos entonces realmente
también sobre habido cortes sobre
desigualdad salarial realmente han
tocado en todos los temas estamos
contentos y orgullosos de su trabajo
claudia y una última palabra sobre los
premios que entrega este festival porque
hay varios premios a los mejores
cortometrajes del festival funciona con
un sistema de becas de becas de ayuda a
la producción entonces los cineastas
ganadores optan a dos grandes premios el
gran premio francia y gran premio
internacional cada uno de ellos de
veinte mil euros no entonces es una
ayuda para lanzar su carrera y para en
el año que sigue con la ayuda de
acompañados de un equipo de producción
puedan realizar un proyecto pues con
medios más profesionales vamos a
si ellos han conseguido destacar con un
cortometraje de un minuto hecho juntas
son un teléfono móvil un celular y han
conseguido comprar algo tan interesante
tienen la oportunidad de llegar a ganar
el premio pues bueno seguir trabajando
con vídeos más profesionales es la idea
pues muchísimas gracias claudia
rodríguez del festival mobile film
festival por darnos todos estos detalles
sobre la competencia este año los
invitamos justamente a consultar en
internet estos 60 cortometrajes muchas
gracias
a banda
de francia damos un salto a bélgica y
suiza los habitantes de estos dos países
siguen confinados debido a la pandemia
pero a diferencia de lo que sucede en
francia los gobiernos belga y suizo
decidieron mantener las librerías
abiertas considerando que el libro es un
bien esencial para sobrevivir al
encierro nos amplía melissa barras
la complace en bruselas está vacía pero
las librerías se mantienen abiertas
alrededor a pesar de la segunda
cuarentena que decretó el gobierno belga
en la librería copies ma ha sido un
alivio para empleados y clientes
bélgica considera que los libros son
esenciales porque así lo consideran sus
habitantes manifestó
me parece muy bien porque es importante
seguir informándose y leyendo con la
misma decisión se ha tomado y ginebra
donde restaurantes y bares siguen
cerrados no así las librerías que
reciben a sus clientes como la histórica
para ello lo que sentimos en la primera
cuarentena que los clientes estaban
frustrados cuando volvimos a abrir hubo
una ola de clientes con sed y necesidad
de lectura en ese período
francia en cambio no considera la compra
de libros como esencial pero los
libreros han ingeniado sistemas de
compra en línea que los clientes pueden
pasar a buscar
gracias melisa barra y agregamos que el
cierre en francia de los comercios no
esenciales como precisamente las
librerías ha desatado una virulenta
campaña contra amazon numerosos sectores
han hecho un llamado al boicot de la
plataforma de venta en línea le reclaman
entre otros
acaparar el 20 por ciento de las compras
en internet en toda francia en
detrimento de los pequeños comercios y
ahora ya de a dar un vistazo a la
actualidad musical en francia y hoy
vamos a hablarles de un dúo de jóvenes
sin complejos ni muy activos en estos
tiempos de covite se llaman ya cloud
fever y acaban de sacar un nuevo disco
bajo el título erótico y es precisamente
de lo que nos va a hablar natale
olivares hola natalia hola maría
carolina ya lots y ver cómo lo dices es
un dúo musical y han definido su estilo
como electro pop erótico o electrónico
erótico y suena así
[Música]
sí sí
o no
[Música]
y con esta música ya la fiba pretende
encarar el invierno la tristeza del
invierno parisino y los hemos conocido
justamente en parís en el distrito
número 13 para hablar de ese disco que
se llama erótico nos gusta hablar de
nuestra música refiriéndonos a los
artistas que nos inspiran creemos que es
más significativo nos inspiramos mucho
en sears y cannes book serón me agarra
para los grupos más clásicos y del lado
más tropical nos inspiramos en grupos
como polo y pan y la fama que también
nos dio ganas de cantar en francés
[Música]
y ya está
la música de charlotte se habla de sexo
pero con elegancia
buscando que la desnudez no sea ni un
complejo ni un tabú es siempre cuando
ella sea tratada con respeto y elegancia
nuestros textos son usados porque nos
fascina muchísimo todo lo erótico la
fantasía todo lo que tenga que ver con
los cuerpos desnudos queríamos hablar de
sexo sin ser vulgares hablar de
sexualidad sensualidad y realmente sin
que sea un tabú o algo vergonzoso tenía
que ser simplemente poesía también
queremos que la gente deje de sonrojarse
cuando hablamos de desnudez y si
tratamos de transmitir este mensaje a
través de texto es genial es hacer
[Música]
esos movimientos
este dúo dinámico volvió de una gira que
lo llevó a países centroamericanos como
honduras costa rica el salvador
guatemala etcétera etcétera y quisieron
aprovechar el paso por el carrusel de
las artes para lanzar este mensaje
queremos volver a centroamérica esperen
nos la pasamos muy bien con ustedes
recibimos todos sus mensajes en las
redes sociales y de verdad queremos
volver volveremos a verte
[Música]
este es era un extracto del disco
erótico de jungle fever esperando saber
cuándo se podrá volver a viajar
muchísimas gracias natal olivares por
esta crónica musical sobre los charlotte
ciber y justamente vamos a terminar con
la música de este dúo parisino guayos
para despedirnos de ustedes muchísimas
gracias por su sintonía cuídense mucho y
hasta la próxima
jaua
[Música]